all right last night Michael avenatti
was arrested on suspicion of domestic
abuse charge it didn't they take long
for Hollywood liberals like Alyssa
Milano to disavow him and the view
co-hosts well today suddenly our fans a
due process where did all this come from
it was very upsetting to hear this very
disappointing if it proves to be true I
will disavow him
I think he should take a polygraph test
hmm just to clear the air I think that
that would help him yeah and then we'll
see what happens what drives me crazy is
the hypocrisy in these moments when it's
who you who you like that you want to
believe and I think if you believe in
due process with Cavan I should also
believe in due process with Michael
avenatti we don't know a lot we don't
know who the alleged victim is but if
true I you know I'm so disappointed I'm
so disappointed and I agree with you we
would have to disavow him media is such
a different tone especially compared to
the way they treated Brett Kavanaugh
joining us now Washington Times
columnist Monica Crowley former White
House press secretary Ari Fleischer re
you know I'm not a registered Republican
I'm a registered conservative
Republicans screw things up a lot they
really do and one of the things I gave
them credit for
they handled the Cavanaugh case with the
seriousness yeah it deserved they I
think they did it right and they had the
hearings they went through the evidence
now we have a point where avenatti Julie
sweat Nick they're now being
investigated I believe in the
presumption of innocence and due process
avenatti did not now you see the media
tone change reaction look number one I I
take no joy in this anytime somebody is
arrested it might go to prison nobody
should celebrate this I agree but due
process and you're innocent until proven
guilty can never be slogans in America
they must be real they must be the way
our justice system is built on that we
all respect Michael avenatti had no
respect for either for innocent until
proven guilty or due process and that's
what he tried to do to Brett Kavanaugh
now it's come full circle and now he has
to deal with it he's lucky that because
of people like Brett Kavanaugh
in the Constitution he will have his due
process in his day in court
the one thing reported TMZ that could be
problematic if that turns if that turns
out to be true is apparently when he ran
in and the day after and the words she
hit me first if that came out and that's
true Monica that's problematic in my
mind that would be problematic for
anybody is that is that his defense well
she hit me first I mean it's not says he
didn't do any of it to be fair to him
right look all of these Hollywood
liberals and and others who embrace
Michael avenatti as some sort of hero of
the resistance they're all learning
right now that you live by the avenatti
and you die by the avenatti
okay he will have his his say he will
have his day in court he will have his
own legal representation as he's
entitled to
he's very ironic that he was first in
line trying to deny that to Brett
Kavanaugh and right by the way President
Trump as well with his representation of
stormy Daniels a lot of these women who
just blindly embraced this guy without
looking into his background it means
going through a very messy divorce his
ex-wife had a sworn statement in those
proceedings where she claimed that he
emotionally abused her so there may or
may not be a pattern of behavior here
with mr. avenatti blindly race to
embrace him only because he opposed
President Trump and was trying to lead
the charge to destroying him is
despicable on MSNBC and C 108 and 200
total or whatever the numbers but on
those two channels in particular over
100 what about re when people when these
issues come up they don't know any of
the facts they know an allegations been
made
no corroboration and then when you get
deeper into it some like in the case of
Professor Ford you know it finds out she
identified an eyewitness to the incident
who said it didn't happen right in that
case Sweatt next allegation was so over
the top from the from the get-go and
then she changed their story but when
people say I believe her
without knowing anything about the case
what does that mean because that happens
a lot now I believe we women have a
right to be believed I think when
serious allegations are made we need to
take them seriously and the women who
made the allegations against Bill
Clinton are still largely not believed
by those on the left look it's a
terrible hypocrisy if the person is a
woman who is attacking saying that a
Republican did something wrong immoral
the entire left says women are made to
be able should be believed right from
the start no investigation necessary I
believe yet now they're all pausing it
should be one constant standard it
should be the Republican standard it
should be the due process standard it
should be the innocent until proven
guilty standard for one and for all
regardless of ideology that is about
bright kalian approved and as he at his
hearings the left needs to stop this I
believe anybody if they attack
Republicans let's just have a due
process yeah and it shouldn't be
political these issues are too serious
these charges are too serious the issue
is too serious
nobody wants anybody that abuses women
to get away with it nobody no person
with a conscience or a soul Monica what
about the I believe before we know
anything yeah you know I think we're
starting to see a turning of of this you
know the me2 movement started out with a
very noble purpose it's been weaponized
we saw that with the Cavanaugh hearings
and now I think with the avenatti case
we might have a tipping back to the idea
that justice should be blind and equally
applied I hope so alright the re re good
to see you and Monica good to see you
thank you thanks